you have to really uh try and see where
uh where you can identify needs
this is all this is marketing is all
about it's about
identifying the needs and finding the
right
uh the right product to to
to match those needs
[Music]
shirley seigel thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders good
morning
thank you good morning and thank you for
having me
it's a pleasure to have you we're
calling calling from a sunny morning
here in tel aviv but but it actually
it's not your preferred weather
you mentioned to me that your mother for
some really weird reason is
foggy rain i don't know i'm a broken
israeli i think
i was my probably my soul was born
somewhere in the
prairies of uh poland i like the
drizzling i like it
where it's nice and gloomy that's where
i'm happiest
but i'm born here so i i go along with a
flow what can i do
so you're gonna have to go along with
the beautiful weather and the beautiful
sun that goes on the beach but it's okay
because today we're talking about we're
talking about your journey we're talking
about
and being a marketing director at
various companies very very well known
in israel
all the way from basic to silicon to zap
companies that really are marketing is
part of their core
you know ideation and innovation uh we
know how
difficult the market is in is also i'm
excited to talk about that but i'm also
excited to talk about your experience
with the 8200 international alumni
community
and and and how that relates back to
serving in the 8200 units so charlie
take me back how do you start your
journey out of 8200
what is sort of like your thinking
process as you go along
oh i was uh in a very traditional
thinking process
okay i need to go to the university tel
aviv university the best university the
best place because i'm 82 3200
and and that's where we went and i think
the click happened uh during marketing
uh and uh the ba of uh
business administration in the tel aviv
university
it was uh it was like falling in love
suddenly uh the way uh i
understood about how to influence how to
understand and
influence people's behavior that was
where i found myself in my
natural element uh i remember it
distinctly i said oh
i found what this is what i want to do
um
and from that point on uh my aim was to
go
to the best places uh in israel and
and later on uh international
to the best places where the marketing
challenges are the ones that will
will be the one that will actually blow
my mind
uh so started up for uh one of the
one of the best companies and but
actually celcom i think was
probably uh the one that really uh
formed my uh
my marketing uh personality
uh because salcombe at the time was a
company for the big numbers
and this is marketing for me this is the
real challenge in marketing it's taking
a whole um a world
of of numbers and
uh trying to find the story behind them
and uh and not only try and find the
story behind them make
your story so that it works and so this
is like sounds like uh
lit 101 no but it's marketing 101
um so but it starts with huge excel
files uh alpo
and age and you have to really
uh try and see where uh
where you can identify needs this is all
this is marketing is all about it's
about identifying
the needs and finding the right uh
the right product to to uh
to match those needs and funnily enough
those needs will appear on excel sheets
uh they will also appear on focus groups
and something that little people know
but
it will also appear when when you talk
to colleagues
and we had some of the greatest success
stories
coming out not from focus groups and not
from talking to
customers and not from looking at excel
sheets
but you just how about if we did this
price plan
and no it won't work we run that
with surveys we run that with focus
group
everybody says it won't work and it
works like a charm
because sometimes it's about a good
intuition
and believing in something that's
logical
and uh and going with it all the way
sometimes your customers are
not um uh are not believing
the you you they go for the pay as you
go
and yes they say okay let's let's try
packages and say no
we don't want packages but once the
packages come
and are offered to them they go for
packages
so you just have to try a lot of the
time you just have to try and
know that you're going to fail sometime
miserably but
you just have to try and give it a good
try every once in a while go beyond
go against everything everybody says
and try a new concept um because this
not only uh benefits uh the organization
it also benefits yourself
you know that sometimes you have to try
something new
go against the flow uh fail and
sometimes you get great success and you
understand that um
it's not always about uh harvesting it
from
the excels and from the customers it's
also about
finding the ideas that will um generate
later on uh good growth uh options
um 100 yeah
and i have to ask because in cell com in
silicon one of the one of the incredible
positions that you've held which is
fascinating to me is customer retention
right
and uh i i know from from living in
israel how
competitive uh this uh this
this industry is so can you tell me a
little bit about cell common
and what was really you know your your
position going into this role which is
incredibly incredibly difficult
incredibly competitive so tell me a
little bit about what it was like
so it was not it's not only the greatest
the the the better part i think of of
working the marketing they're being
in charge of retention but the timing
was
uh an unbelievably amazing timing
because at that time
uh the the minister of communication
cancelled the the um
living fees so uh
so actually there were no uh barriers
into into moving from one company to the
other
um and if this has happened i think in
about two or three months uh we knew it
was coming we didn't believe it was
coming
we prepared ourselves but once it came
it started an
unbelievably um fierce uh
war price between the the companies
because suddenly
there were no barriers to to leaving any
companies
uh you had the number uh you didn't get
uh
there was no there were no fines
hallelujah and in in i think in two
months
the prices uh dropped in two hundred
three hundred percent and uh
unbelievable
and you add new mvnos
uh going into the game and you know
they had nothing to lose they can for
all they know they can uh
name a price tag of 19 shekels uh which
is like
i don't know six eight dollars and
they'll gain
uh and also the regulatory um
procedures uh allow them really
encourage them
to add as many subscribers as they can
up until such a time where if they had
this amount
they'll be they'll be able to go further
so
everything was uh laid out to a
good healthy unbelievable price uh
war and this happened on overnight
and what you do is you form what what
you say yeah you form come on
you form a wall room which convenes
every day at 12 you have to look at the
numbers
you have to identify where you get the
most turnout
out and what what are you what are you
going to do in return
and selcom is a big company but at the
time it was five thousand
six seven mma wow a very
large company um and you know that large
companies
are not in the habit of working very
fast
but this was uh i think a defining
moment for cercom because
um you actually saw how a very large
company
working very slowly and very
mythologically can
uh convene at 12 uh p.m
and uh decide that this is a price plan
that will give
the best solution and by five o'clock
you have the price plan implant you have
the price plan in place
after going all through uh so many
people
and development and you have the price
plan in place
and you're ready for um for 8 a.m
uh next day to launch it um
this is how things should happen
everywhere
and this is where i got and this is
where personally i get the kick out of
you know i
said that in stockholm the best thing
that you came round
eight a.m eight nine you said okay i
need to do this
that this is how my day but by 11 and
always
11 a.m was a magic moment something
happened
something happened that you went oh no
what am i doing next and you you you had
to really
um uh make a handstand
and uh forget everything you wanted to
do by that point
and try and do something else just to
just to match reality
um unbelievable so this was that period
and it was an
awesome period really uh so much
adrenaline
i'm sure so much excitement um
really working around the clock but um
really this is
this is a magic moment for for any
company and
and for every professional where you
you actually see that you have no limits
and
things you thought that can cannot be
done can be done
everything can be done if you just put
your mind to it um
100 at that point yeah
and from that point on the the the churn
the the uh loyalty uh policies
actually changed uh 103
180 degrees because up to that point
uh we've had big loyalty programs
and large campaigns and great benefits
and it was all about uh surprise and
delight um
you know you now you have this amazing
benefit and you can take out all your
friends out
for breakfast on our expense or you can
buy
books uh for very low prices that was uh
that was the policy up to that point um
and the policy from that point onward
because it was obvious
that people no longer uh found it
interesting they said okay just give me
the best price
okay and and let me be don't call me
don't give me benefits i'm not
interested just give me the best price
because that was what uh um
energized the market at that point um
and uh and and from that point on
it was all of it was a lot about
the service the ongoing service and the
ongoing um
relationship between the subscriber
the customer and ourselves it was about
bringing values
of being very honest
uh very outgoing
um the same hebrew transparency
and that was uh a value that became
very important during that time um
no more no more you know
complicated price plans no more uh
services uh add-on services being
very transparent to your uh to your
subscribers
um creates um one magic word
which is trust and 100
that's where you get loyalty i think i
think that's just
that that's phenomenal yeah yeah
and surely i have to ask because i have
to ask because i'm fascinated also by
your work with zap
i love zap it's a group that that has
three
three subgroups that you were in charge
of the also they're marketing
uh rest coal missile and and
so tell me tell me what what lessons did
you bring with you
from uh selkom and besik
as you're transitioning to be director
of marketing for these very different
companies
right they're not the same it's not it's
not the same customer experience
not it's not always the same customers
so what what lessons did you bring in
what new challenges did you have to face
yes so that was actually um the israeli
yelp
and um and the the
the challenge there that it's always
about the marketing challenge
it's always a and the marketing
challenge there was uh
actually going both ways it's a b2b
uh challenge because you work the
advertisers
are small medium businesses in israel
which i knew very well for my time
working in in
selkom and basic but also it's
the israeli uh it's really really crowd
you have to please uh the people who who
that
that will eventually coming to rest
coming to
deliveries coming to uh the wedding
website
um so it's a double-sided challenge and
of this is uh the part where you know i
can talk
for for hours and hours but um
it's also about finding how everything
uh
intermediate finding how i give uh the
um the people who come in the website uh
a definite value and we did that
actually in
in rest first and and then onwards uh
for michelle
by personalization and you you think
personalization it's so obvious
but but to take a website that was um
you know just a restaurant website with
uh with ratings and
nice pictures and making in it into a
website that
actually uh when you come in michael and
when i come in we see
two different websites you get the the
recommendations for you you get the
content
that that will match your needs and i'll
get
now get different content different
recommendations
and by adding personalization into these
websites
we actually um drove the win-win
situation
more servers came in a lot more surface
came in
the website ceo seo went up the roof
and our advertisers were happy because
not only we brought more traffic
we bought more relevant traffic for them
um
and when you ask what's the uh what
what what connects um zak group
and you know uh the the israeli yelp and
and celcom it's about identifying the
needs it's
always about that identifying the needs
and talking to the customers and really
understanding
what makes what makes everybody ticks
and
uh going on from there developing the
product that would
um that would suit everybody's needs
and also for me it's technology
so i'm a big fan of everything that's
techie
and really when you see
the last 20 years and what technology
brought in for marketing
uh this is a
small time revolution because we went on
from from starting out from just having
surveys
and measuring traffic into really having
concise insights into the buyer persona
and having um immediate
which is awesome immediate feedback
about how
campaigns going and after uh going into
one big campaign but going into
uh 20 30 sometimes a hundred micro
campaigns
and just optimizing as we go and seeing
what
what works best for us so this is
also uh um uh one thing in common it's
it's technology and how you can use it
to to be a better marketer and
and to develop better products and and
making your
customers happy which is the basic for
every loyal customer right i think
what i'm taking away from this is is
primarily you know the the
really the art behind marketing and
really the the perspective of really
understanding what makes
people take and really what what they're
looking for in forming this relationship
not just with your customers but forming
this relationship with what you're
marketing and the product that you're
using that you're
using to market because that
relationship it sounds that you have to
really be
transparent and honest with it in order
for it to be to come out authentic and
to really gain the loyalty and trust of
the customers
surely 20 minutes go by so fast and i
want to thank you for being so generous
with your time
it's unbelievable right but we do have
the most important question
we have the most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
okay so um disclaimer
i did uh think about it
ahead of time curious first thing
is curious i'm i'm impossible
on the bordering of uh really going into
every detail
um people that's that's the most
interesting thing you you should know
you know
how many interviews have you had so far
over 200
that's the most interesting thing
talking to people
and and learning things things that are
new to you
so curious energetic uh and i think it
came across you know
bring it bring it bring it all i i love
being in
good uh dynamic places
and the last thing that i'm very hands
on
you know uh i really like to get my
hands dirty
i will always be the one who goes so let
me handle that let me just
because you do learn things by by your
own experience
um don't don't go too far away from
where
everything happens get your hands dirty
because that's where you really learn
i love it surely thank you very much
best of luck with your continuing a
great work with the
marketing direction and thank you for
thank you for the inspiration over these
past 20 minutes
thank you very much have a good one bye
you